[Music]
when you see the players get the ball
mayhem for the first time it's a cross
between intrigue and excitement it's
great to see him try and bounce the ball
and to see it actually bounce away
it can make the best of people look
really really silly the number one sport
in Australia is Australian rules
football it's basically a cross between
rugby and soccer and the fans go crazy
for it there's one problem they don't
have enough tall people so what do they
do they come to the states this combines
the u.s. AFL combine and we started this
four years ago basically in a search for
four guys six foot seven and above and
these tall American athletes they don't
really need to know a lot about
Australia
the home of the kangaroos I think I know
a lot of kangaroos I hit a lot about
kangaroos and spiders and snakes in
selecting these athletes we
predominantly look for guys that are
hungry most of the participants
predominantly come from basketball the
concept of basketball in terms of the
athlete being in traffic and having
spatial awareness and those sorts of
things is really transferable to our
game which is good news because less
than 2% of college basketball players
will make it to the pros the Australian
Football League gives them another
chance to live out their dreams of being
a pro athlete most of the participants
are quite shocked when they say the game
for the first time the question is what
are the athletes think of all this when
I got to come well I thought it was fake
actually I thought it was a scam first
thing I thought that was a scam I
thought there was a contact and wrong
person absolutely what is Australian
football skepticism aside how do you
teach these guys a game they never even
heard of before
so the comboing kicks off in the early
pace with a physical testing and then
start to build into the skills the
basics of hand boiling the ability to
see what they like with their hands then
we can start to get into the more
competitive stuff where they might crash
& bash into each other which they love
that
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Mason Cox he played basketball
at Oklahoma State two years ago he was
just like one of these guys on the
combine now he's playing professionally
in Australia they can be one of the 22
superstars out there on an AFL team it's
a fantastic opportunity for these guys
to continue their professional career
[Music]
how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this doesn't played
anywhere else in the world so yeah like
it's serious like we want to win
[Music]
we're gonna watch unicycle football it's
football on unicycles you stick the NFL
rules as closely as possible says there
a few exceptions goes riding a unicycle
we play five on five two receivers a
blocker a center and a quarterback
everything has to be done on a wheel the
second your foot touches the ground
you're done
each team plays 14 games there's 56
regular-season games total the wildcard
playoffs and playoffs and then the
stupid ball every Sunday some people
have been doing this for 10 years now my
team the black outs were undefeated and
we're gonna be playing the reigning
champs the herons bulldoze them over
this game is very important because we
want to maintain our undefeated status
leading up to the Super Bowl they're
definitely going for us they're
practicing just for us
I think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them is the
level of play we're crashing at 15 miles
an hour it's not a joke
some people get seriously injured most
people learn to ride unicycle because
they came and witnessed this event and
they're like I've got to do this once
you catch that first ball once you get
that first brush once you hear the crowd
scream your name once that's a feeling
you can't get anywhere else that's
almost like a religion church to us here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle it's also a sport
I've cherished every minute of it you
can't replace it anything there's
nothing else like it at all
[Music]
[Music]
football it's a 360-degree game there's
no padding there is a high risk involved
in it because it is a full contact sport
and you really can cop it from any angle
but we're pretty tough and we get
straight back up on coffee I'm Chloe and
I'm a loon football let's go girls
[Music]
IFL or the Australian Football League is
best described as a combination of rugby
football and soccer I think if you asked
any Australian it's a really big deal it
defines us it's a part of our culture I
think everyone has AFL team that they
support my uncle played football for
Collingwood so I grew up watching him
and I immediately wanted to do it back
when I was a little girl I actually
played football for three to four years
but then there's that drop-off that a
lot of girls have because there is no
pathway into a women's sporting career
in 2017 a women's league was officially
introduced good stretch for all
Australian but if a woman's change the
path of life for me that I never thought
I'd have it's brought out the little
girl's dream that I had back when I did
play football
I think the AFL women's is breaking down
a lot of barriers that once existed
amongst women in sport no matter what
race what sexual identity you are it
really doesn't matter and anyone can
play some people just don't agree that
women should be playing football so
that's probably a challenge that I face
and that the whole league face as well
the best way to react to all the
criticism is just not to react at all
and keep doing what we enjoy one hope
that I have is that if any little girl a
boy clicks on the TV they know full well
that that's a sport that they can go
into no matter if it's being played by
men or women
[Music]
there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd you can definitely
feel the atmosphere there's a vibe in
the air there's the energy in the air
there's a sound it's amazing to hear the
fans especially when we were on the
tunnel
I'm Jake Wilson I'm the long snapper at
the University of Southern California
Trojans I'm completely blind I have no
eyes I went in to play football with the
mentality that I had nothing to lose
longtime ian is an art you definitely
have the mechanics but a lot of it just
feel feeling that ball come off your
fingertips in a spiral how hard you're
throwing it you know where you're
releasing it just kind of getting that
velocity and in that and the accuracy
lice unfair
football's unfair but at the same time
it's up to you of how far you want to
take yourself when I was eight months
old I was diagnosed with a rare form of
eye cancer called retinal blastoma
when the doctors found my cancer it was
completely taken over my left eye so
they almost immediately removed my left
eye from there on you know just a cycle
of you know the cancer coming back they
would fight it out with treatments
doctors finally said listen we've pretty
much exhausted all all treatment options
that's safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye growing up in the
2000s where Coach Carroll was so
dominant with USC it was hard not to be
a USC fan I always loved football I
continued to play flag football my
eighth grade year after losing my sight
it was not anything close tackle
football as I entered high school I
decided enough to play football for my
freshman and sophomore year it really
was something that I didn't think I
could do but eventually my left of the
game really overcame any doubts and I
learned how to be nice
I just love the camaraderie of football
I love being part of the team love
putting on you know just the pads and
the Jersey and stuff being part of the
team what was enough just that to get me
to try girls are just as good as boys
and anything we know how to hit we know
how to run and we can definitely play
football so when I heard boys chanting
beat that girl hate that girl all made
me wanna do was beat them even better
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Sam Gordon I'm 14 years old and I
started the first female tackle football
league I've been playing with the boys
since I was nine years old in my very
first season I scored 35 touchdowns not
like 1,900 yards sometimes after I'd
beat him the parents would come out onto
the field to grab their son's case and
be like don't let a girl beat you I
wanted to start the girls tackle
football league after talking at a
school assembly and asking the question
how many girls here would want to play
tackle football almost every hand in the
room went up so I got the idea like okay
if there's this many at this one school
imagine how many there are in Utah or
just in the nation so I talked to my dad
and we talked with some other people
after a while we had the first season of
the Utah girls tackle football league up
and running
football is the last frontier in girl
sports and if you think about it girls
can play on girls teams in every sport
that you can think of except for the
country's most popular sport we limited
participation to 50 girls those spots
filled up in less than a week the
following year we had 100 girls and then
this season we've had over 200 girls who
are playing every year we keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger will be
amazing for it to go into high schools
colleges and even its own professional
league and that's gonna be a tough goal
to reach about I am really ambitious and
I feel like we could do it with the
girls you could tell that everybody
really wants to be there and so
everybody is just super into it and
always willing to learn or with the
girls
every practice is just an awesome time
[Music]
you
[Music]